madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal la polémique dans la vallée de
la tarentaise
après ce samedi noir qui a paralysé
l'accès aux stations les automobilistes
ont passé la nuit dans des hébergements
mis à leur disposition
le salon de l'agriculture ferme ses
portes plus de six cent mille visiteurs
une affluence record et le plaidoyer de
jacques chirac qui est déterminé à
défendre les intérêts du monde agricole
demain s'ouvre à paris le procès de
l'attentât du dc-10 d'uta 170 personnes
ont trouvé la mort dix ans d'instruction
six accusés des services libyens qui
sont absents théâtre avec copenhague
pièce qui met en scène la rencontre
entre deux savants pleine guerre
mondiale tous deux prix nobel
le danois niels bohr interprété par
pierre vaneck et le scientifique
allemand eisenberg que joue
admirablement niels arestrup qui est
l'invité de notre journal
nous avons tout de suite cette édition
avec cette information qui nous est
parvenue via un peu moins d'une heure
stanley kubrick le réalisateur américain
qui a signé nombre de chefs-d'oeuvre
2001 odyssée de l'espace orange
mécanique barry lyndon shining de
stanley kubrick est mort en grande
bretagne où il vivait en reclus depuis
des années un talent inestimable à
cinéma de référence qui aura marqué
cette dernière moitié du siècle
nicolas cornu langlois précurseur
prémonitoire son film orange mécanique
en 1971 avait dénoncé la violence de
notre temps et fait éclater son
inlassable interrogation sur la
condition humaine mise en valeur par une
époustouflante technique et qu'est ce
que la dacie déboutant ce monde
reconnue dès 1957 avec les sentiers de
la gloire puis spartacus en 1960 et
l'adaptation miraculeuse de lolita de
vladimir nabokov sur la possibilité d
êtres à communiste et après ce réalisme
fantastique
il débouche en pleine science-fiction
avec 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace film le
plus ambitieux avec ses perspectives
métaphysique miraculeuse avec barry
lyndon le raffinement la décoration leur
met au premier rang
ces passionnés et ils voulaient que tout
le monde soit aussi parfait et est
passionnée par là qu'on faisait que lui
kubrick était tout à la fois réalisateur
auteur et producteur il était né en 1928
aux états unis mais avait choisi
l'angleterre pour vivre jeanine le
docteur folamour fils metal jacket
furent ses autres succès depuis deux ans
il préparé dans le plus grand secret
eyes wide shut avec nicole kidman et tom
cruise se devait être l'événement
cinématographique de la fin de cette
année sa mort l'a devancé je vous
propose à présent d'écouter les
premières réactions à la disparition des
stanley kubrick celle du cinéaste
bertrand tavernier qui fut un temps
l'attaché de presse de kubrick il a
vengé tous les metteurs en scène que les
studios fait trimer haut que le que les
studios dans les studios ont charcuté
les films qu'ils ont dont ils ont abîmé
les oeuvres kubrick par son obsession
maniaque de de son film soir en montrer
montée montrer comme il le désirait
comme il le voulait il avant j'ai plein
de metteur en scène aller chez lui
c'était sorte de petit parce que la
maison n'était pas extraordinairement
les choses mais c'est une sorte de fort
knox de de xanadu s'était plaint des
écriteaux do not enter no trespassing
beware of the dog bee ware touched adore
enfin il fallait pas toucher la poignée
parce que tout était reliée
électroniquement à la police c'est un an
de protection c'est un homme donc je me
demande comment il a pu mourir irène
12h40 en hommage à stanley kubrick
france 2 diffusera orange mécanique une
première diffusion à la télévision dans
l'actualité de ce dimanche la polémique
autour de l'engorgement récurrent de la
vallée de la tarentaise la polémique ne
s'est pas éteinte 24 heures après ses
embouteillages monstres qui ont paralysé
les axes menant aux stations benoît
gadret enfin arrivé enfin le ski
l'espace et le grand air oubliée la
galère d'hier les heures passées dans
les ralentissements la circulation en
accordéon à bouchon singer et
aujourd'hui vous êtes content d'être ici
oui beaucoup d'étrangers ont été bloqués
entre albertville et moutier ces
touristes pour lesquels les stations de
tarentaise font de gros efforts de
promotion il est certain qu'une arrivée
comme celle ci est une très mauvaise
opération pour notre notoriété
les stations de tarentaise une trentaine
en tout affiche une capacité de 330
mille lits cela représente la moitié du
parc français pour les sports d'hiver
à cette époque de l'année une seule
route les desserts la nationale 90
or cette voie étroite est régulièrement
l'objet d'éboulement qui met en péril
les automobilistes et gênent la
circulation
d'où la présence de filets de protection
il ya ces éboulements parce que on est
en montagne que la nature est souvent
plus forte que nous on a beau faire une
quantité de protection donc comme vous
avez pu le voir
partout les protections c'est pas non
plus à l'infini s'est jamais à 100% pour
sécuriser davantage et assurer la
fluidité du trafic il faudrait dresser
des merlons construire tunnels et
viaducs
un projet dont le coût est estimé à 183
millions d'euros soit un milliard deux
cents millions de francs on sait ce
qu'il faut faire maintenant il faut que
tous les partenaires se mettent autour
de la table et décider du financement de
ce plan qui est vitale à la fois pour la
sécurité des utilisateurs de la chaussée
et qui pour nous sa voix représente un
des poumons économiques du département
les élus locaux en appelle donc à l'état
pour que des crédits soient débloqués
pour obtenir par la même occasion la
mise à trois voies de la nationale
après moutier un dossier
particulièrement sensible en valais de
tarentaise mais revenons sur ce samedi
noir où les automobilistes sont vus
contraints de gagner des foyers
d'hébergement dans la région
d'albertville la préfecture de savoie
avait mis en place un dispositif
d'urgence pour utiliser ces vacanciers
ambiance plutôt bon enfant
des familles entières qui ont passé la
nuit dans des familles d'accueil dans
des locaux municipaux avant de reprendre
la route
tout ce matin alors qu'il est la
circulation est redevenue fluide dans la
vallée de la tarentaise un bouchon de 6
km sur la fameuse nationale 90 s'est
résorbé en milieu d'après midi
c'est après demain que reprendront les
discussions à bruxelles autour de la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
un dossier difficile que prend à coeur
le gouvernement et l'elysée jacques
chirac qui s'est rendue ce matin au
salon de l'agriculture
plus de quatre heures d'un bain de foule
pour cette présidentielle visite au
cours de laquelle une nouvelle fois le
chef de l'état a dit sa détermination à
défendre le monde agricole véronique
satellite jan cornet
emporté par la foule est au plus près
des vaches jacques chirac a soigné
pendant plus de quatre heures sa vieille
complicité avec les agriculteurs
félicitations
elle est douce est lancé
hommage aux produits laitiers soutien à
la filière porcine
le président de la république paye de sa
personne il s'agit de faire plaisir à
tout le monde
la négociation sur la réforme de la
politique agricole européenne bat son
plein et jacques chirac avec jean
glavany ghoul ministre de l'agriculture
à ses côtés affirme keith tiendra bon
nous serons extrêmement vigilants
les paysans plan c peut être assurée
de la détermination de ma détermination
de celles du gouvernement
à défendre
légitimes qui sont d'ailleurs
les intérêts de l'avant
cohabitation oblige le président de la
république et le gouvernement par le don
d'une seule voix mais pour la défense de
l'agriculture jacques chirac ne cède pas
un pouce de terrain
le 36e salon de l'agriculture qui vient
de fermer ses portes aura accueilli plus
de six cent dix mille visiteurs une
affluence record pour ce dernier salon
du siècle passage obligé de tous les
responsables politiques
le bilan de ce rendez vous annuel éric
messier au salon les vaches ne sont pas
folles on y apprend en effet qu'elle ne
mange plus de ces farines carnet qui
leur ont fait perdre la tête
j'arrivais oui mais il y a bon goût de
faire ça qu'ils croient ça il est mérité
pour l'alimentation animale figurez vous
c'est ce message de transparence que
tente de faire passer les professionnels
de l'alimentation animale mais une crise
s'éloigne que déjà une autre se profile
et certains éleveurs s'inquiètent de
savoir si les céréales pour animaux sont
génétiquement modifié en ce qui concerne
l'alimentation s'il ya débat ni manger
les flics ces femmes du caire sur
l'équipe alors comme il n'y a aucun
moyen de contrôle non c'est parce que
voir
pour les agriculteurs cette semaine les
maîtres mots ont été respect de
l'environnement traçabilité qualité qu à
l'heure où à bruxelles on renégocie les
aides à leurs hôtes vers le monde paysan
c'est qu'ils doivent plus que jamais
séduire et se rallier l'opinion publique
il faut arrêter les propos autour d'eux
du coup de l'agriculture pour le pays et
cetera donc il s'agit de montrer que
l'agriculture est un secteur dynamique
avec une haute technicité qui aussi
préserve un certain nombre de valeurs
sur la nature
l'animal de la terre à l'assiette clame
cette enseigne les grandes surfaces
n'ont pas été longues à se caler sur le
nouveau discours du monde rural
ici on défend l'agriculture dite
raisonnée là on s'affiche plutôt bio ces
produits ne représente pour l'instant
que 1 2% du chiffre d'affaires des
supermarchés
mais pour communiquer et rassurer le
consommateur il n'y a rien de mieux
premier tour des élections territoriales
en corse après l'annulation du scrutin
de mars 98 pour fraude électorale
une action qui se déroule un peu plus
d'un an après l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
une élection qui aura donc valeur de
test alors que le gouvernement tente de
restaurer l'état de droit en corse
dès la mi journée la participation était
largement inférieure à celle de l'an
dernier et selon les dernières
estimations seuls 54% des électeurs se
sont rendus aux urnes contre 68 56 % en
mars 98 tarnos bouter olivier robert
malgré le froid et la grisaille les
anciens du village tiennent toujours à
voter les premiers
histoire de montrer l'exemple et de bien
rappeler à quelle famille politique
ils appartiennent c'est le fief de josé
roque
voilà pas tout
vous voyez oui le suivait de jeu vers
ans c'est à vous alors là non non
monsieur n'a pas voté même si cette
année le coeur n'y est pas les corps se
reprennent le chemin des urnes
douze listes et 612 candidats briguent
51 sièges à l'assemblée territoriale
l'invalidation du scrutin de l'an
dernier pour cause de fraude
ici on préfère en plaisanter tu es venu
sauver encore ce continent ce n'est il
mais avec une arme à la mer et le code
électoral
la préfecture elle ne badine pas avec la
sécurité
le bon déroulement du scrutin constitue
une priorité
aujourd'hui les maires et leurs adjoints
avaient comme consigne d'être
intransigeant photos à la maison j'ai
dans plusieurs bureaux de grandes villes
certains électeurs ont pu voter avec des
papiers périmés provoquant la colère de
certains à 19h20 le taux de
participation par rapport à l'an dernier
est en baisse 54% beaucoup de corses
n'ont pas voté et selon les dernières
estimations concernant 30 % des votants
sept des douze listes passe la barre des
5% et sont donc présentes au deuxième
tour la liste de droite de jean baggioni
et josé rossi est en tête devant la
liste du ministre de la fonction
publique emile zuccarelli jean pierre
chevènement a finalement décidé de faire
liste commune avec le parti socialiste
il avait été un temps envisagé de
constituer une liste du mouvement des
citoyens vous européenne
finalement le ministre de l'intérieur au
club de la presse de repas a pris le
parti de faire cause commune avec le
parti socialiste nous écoutons nous
avons considéré que pour peser vraiment
pour préparer l'avenir et compte tenu du
renouvellement de la 2 européenne
il fallait aller à la bataille en se
défaisant un pack avec le parti
socialiste je crois qu'il est important
qu'il y ait une gauche de gouvernement
qui est aussi une gauche de principe qui
s'affirme
en eure-et-loir tout près de dreux
daniel cohn bendit est venu à la
rescousse de dieudonné cet artiste qui a
pour projet d'installer un centre
culturel africain dans cette région qui
se montre franchement hostiles à ce
projet laurent hakim berne numério cohn
bendit les chasseurs et la maréchaussée
la fable est désormais connue même si
cette fois sur les terres de dieudonné
les dix chasseurs se sont montrés plutôt
sage le sable sur les pavés la tête de
liste des verts connaît le refrain cette
fois le sable vient des îles du
pacifique sud
le mariage des cultures et des couleurs
c'est le projet de dieudonné dans un
centre pour l'art africain qui déchaîne
les passions à quelques kilomètres de
route là où l'humoriste avait combattu
le front national aux dernières
législatives
cohn-bendit récemment insulté sur ses
origines est venu dénoncer à scénario
qui semble se reproduit je ne
m'intéresse pas je suis venu soutenir
dieudonné qui a le projet un centre
européen de culture africaine qu'il veut
mettre sur pied avec ce qu'il a gagné
je trouve ça formidable et je voudrais
l'aider a expliqué aux riverains
c'est pas quelque chose qui les menacent
mais c'est quelque chose dont ils
pourraient profiter
folklore africain et folklore politique
aujourd'hui à l'affiché petit théâtre de
dieudonné
l'écologiste à la rescousse de
l'utopiste contre la tolérance à metz
après l incendie la nuit dernière du
palais des sports entièrement ravagé par
les flammes
la possibilité d'un acte criminel est
envisagée par les enquêteurs le feu a
pris à une extrême rapidité il n'y a pas
eu de victime
70 sapeurs pompiers étaient à pied
d'oeuvre pour éteindre les flammes qui
ont embrasé l'édifice qui pouvait
contenir deux mille personnes le
sinistre s'est déclaré une heure après
la fin d'un match de hand ball
c'est donc demain que débutera le 33e
recensement de la france plus de cent
mille employés vont pendant près d'un
mois
réactualisé les dernières données de la
population selon ses méthodes que vous
présente
yann fronty ce jour de juillet ils
étaient des centaines de milliers à
célébrer dans la rue
la victoire des footballeurs français
combien sommes-nous aujourd'hui à vivre
dans notre pays
voici l'objet du 33e recensement qui
débute officiellement dès demain pour se
faire quelques 115 mille agents
recenseurs vont se rendre chez vous afin
de remplir ces questionnaires des agents
recenseurs facilement reconnaissable car
muni de cette carte bar et deux
tricolores ces agents ont des consignes
strictes
ils ne doivent pas rentrer chez vous
sauf s'ils y sont invités ils ne peuvent
pas vous joindre par téléphone
me permet de démontrer auprès des gens
que je vais rencontrer que je suis bien
jean recenseurs et que pour que j'aie
une fonction officielle
mais il ne s'agit pas simplement de nous
compter précisément dans un peu moins
d'un mois l'objectif de ce recensement
sera aussi de mieux cerner le
comportement
le mode de vie de 61 millions
d'habitants recensement indispensable
pour évaluer nos besoins en crèche en
hôpitaux en transport ou encore en liste
une enquête nationale aux résultats
attendus également pour fixer les
subventions versées par l'état aux
communes aux cantons ou encore au
département en fonction de leur
population
bref un recensement obligatoire pour
apprendre à mieux nous connaître
c'est demain que s'ouvre à paris le
procès de l'attentât du dc-10 d'uta dix
ans d'instruction pour tenter de définir
les responsabilités de cet acte
terroriste au cours duquel 170 personnes
ont trouvé la mort au dessus du désert
de ténéré accusés six officiers des
services secrets libyens qui ne seront
pas l'audience le colonel kadhafi
continue de refuser leur extradition
parce qu'elle dit c'est bon
plusieurs soldats français l'ont avoué
cette mission fut la plus pénible de
leur carrière
septembre 89 la france découvre
l'attentât le plus meurtrier qu'elle a
connu à ce jour 170 morts c'était
jean-pierre haine car le mari d'isabelle
qui pilotait l'avion
elle est restée seule avec ses deux
enfants j'ai eu une réaction de refus -
très longtemps parce qu'en fait je pense
que je ne pouvais pas assumer le fait
qu'ils aient une volonté délibérée de
nuire de tuer des tas de gens comme ça
19 septembre le vol ut 772 est à l'heure
il quitte brazzaville pour djamena où il
fait escale avant de re décoller et de
disparaître au dessus du ténéré
la suite est une série d'appels angoissé
de la tour de contrôle la plus proche
mais ut 772 ne répondra plus commence
alors une instruction exceptionnel
d'abord par les moyens engagés
les morceaux de l'appareil sont ramenés
en france pour être patiemment
réassembler on comprend alors mieux les
circonstances de l'explosion
les premières analyses ne laisse aucun
doute c'est bien n'attends pas qu'il
s'agit ces débris d'une valise garde des
traces de pentrite un explosif déjà
utilisé par des terroristes proches de
la libye
jean louis bruguière chargé de
l'instruction commence par se rendre au
congo et son voyage et des plus
instructifs plusieurs témoignages
désignaient un passager mort dans
l'attentât apollinaire mangatany
congolais proche des services secrets
libyens auraient transporté à la valise
piégée apparemment sans savoir qu'elle
devait exploser en vol
les soupçons du juge se portent alors
sur abdallah et lazrag ibrahim n'a elie
et arbas mousse bart trois agents
libyens organisateur présumé de
l'attentât
introuvable des soupçons bien gênant
pour la diplomatie française comment
faire plier mouammar el-kadhafi le chef
d'état libyen clame l'innocence de ses
services et refuse de livrer les
suspects
quatre ans plus tard jean louis
bruguière finira par se rendre à tripoli
il en reviendra avec trois mises en
examen supplémentaire et pas des
moindres parmi les accusés le
lieutenant-colonel senoussi le propre
beau frère de kadhafi
aucun de ces hommes ne sera à l'audience
aucun ne croisera le regard des familles
des victimes qui juge pourtant ce procès
nécessaire ce que j'attendrais
maintenant ce serait que l'état libyen
peut être la personne même de kadhafi
lui même reconnaît son implication dans
cet attentat
vraisemblablement dans d'autres
également la justice pense savoir qui et
comment
manque le pourquoi terrorisme aveugle
présence supposée d'un opposant libyen
dans l'avion l'instruction doit s'en
tenir à des hypothèses invérifiables
pour l'instant jean paul ii a proclamé
ce matin dix nouveaux bienheureux dans
le religieux français ni que la barre
est mort au xviie siècle
ce père a marqué la vie catholique de
son époque notamment à rouen où il fut
le conseiller spirituel des membres du
parlement mais aussi des filles perdues
de la ville
le pape jean paul ii sera béatifié au
cours de son pontificat plus de la
moitié de tous les bienheureux proclamée
par l'église catholique
la 24e cérémonie des césar avec la
consécration de la vie rêvée des anges
qui rafle trois trophées plusieurs
distinctions pour patrice chéreau et son
film ceux qui m'aiment prendront le
train une sérieuse déconvenue pour place
vendôme qui avait pourtant douze
nominations
nicolas cornu langlois présidé par
isabelle huppert la 24e nuit des césar a
décerné un palmarès équilibré
voici le grand vainqueur
le film que vous avez préféré et la vie
rêvée des anges de eric bouquin
meilleure actrice elodie bouchez
les roseaux sauvages d'andré téchiné en
si vous dire quelque chose et le
meilleur espoir féminin passe à renier
les trois césars aussi pour ceux qui
m'aiment prendront le train la photo et
le césar du meilleur réalisateur pour
patrice chéreau et son sixième long
métrage se demandent toujours où je suis
j'ai fait du théâtre il ya du
signalement comporte pas bien mais
pourquoi il fait du théâtre pour que
j'aie du cinéma on avait montré dit là
simplement que ma place parmi vous
n'était pas incongru voilà prix du
meilleur second rôle
dominique blanc c'est un césar que je
voudrais offrir entièrement
passionnément et totalement à patrice
chéreau autre ton pour la comédie le
dîner de cons meilleurs scénaristes
francis veber le lauréat est assez
jacques villeret dans le dîner
meilleur second rôle daniel prévost
merci beaucoup
on aime tous le cinéma à en mourir et
d'en mourir il ya rire
et moi je vais faire ça voilà et on
arrive parfois dans cette soirée
conventionnelle avec la robe
hallucinante de victoria abril et le
couple infernal le beurre et la belle
monsieur et madame karembeu compta fils
commence à tomber s'appelle jean
rochefort nous a touchés pour son césar
d'honneur ovationné par le public tout
comme johnny depp qui innovent dans
l'art de remercier avec son propre
enregistrement
je suis très honoré de recevoir ce
cadeau de la france parce que j'aime et
je respecte beaucoup votre pays et lors
de ces césars ne ferait qu on pense sur
18 sont allés à des longs métrages
coproduits par france 2 ou france 3
cinéma dont la vie rêvée des anges et
ceux qui m'aiment prendront le train
les premiers défilés du prêt-à-porter de
l'hiver prochain avec sur le podium
aujourd'hui les créations de jérôme
dreyfuss ce jeune styliste nouvelle
coqueluche de la mode qui n'en est
pourtant qu'à son deuxième défilé
ce film est l eric de l'agneau alain
look at you
quand on a des yeux rieurs comme cela la
vie vous sourit jérôme dreyfuss le dit
lui même il suffit parfois d'y croire
très fort pour que ça marche
c'était un rêve de gamin quand d'autres
ou jouer aux billes lui ne voulait
qu'une seule chose faire des roms
ria le dos et suggère de lui
on va voir le travail paraît si je ne
trompe pas mais oui comme elle accepte
de défiler pour lui au tarif modique
en à peine un an jérôme dreyfuss a
réussi à détourner tous les regards
excuse moi est-ce que tout croire
toujours c'est un genre
certainement j'ai un petit complexe
d'infériorité
avec l'aide de quelques potes et presque
sans moyens jérôme dreyfuss à 24 ans a
aussi appris à être gestionnaire
coursier ou secrétaire il porte tout à
bout de bras aboud enthousiasme tout
l'argent que je gagne
il va y barre dans des robes pour qu'on
aille part pour faire des robes pour des
femmes et il n'y va pas pour moi mais au
bout du compte mais je vous eu ces bêtes
quoi mail quel pied
quel pied quand renvoyer les roms sur
les filles est tout à la fois qu'on a eu
besoin d'argent fonctions
oh pardon vainqueur
les grandes maisons de couture devrait
se rendre compte qu'il n'est pas
toujours besoin de trouver des talents à
l'échangé de plus la jeune création
française se porte bien
il suffit parfois tout simplement de lui
laisser sa chance du football en coupe
de la ligue metz s'est qualifié cet
après midi pour les demi finales en
battant toulouse les deux équipes
étaient à égalité 3 but partout à la fin
des prolongations les messins se
qualifiant dans l'épreuve des tirs au
but
formula avec à melbourne le grand prix
d'australie à rebondissements une
véritable hécatombe avec 14 abandons
rien que ça finalement la victoire
pourrait d'irvine sur ferrari le pilote
britannique compte sa première victoire
de grandpré alexandre kara depuis près
de six ans qu'il court en formule 1 est
dur vine a l'habitude en général
d'arroser la victoire des autres et si
cette nuit le coéquipier de michael
schumacher a bu à la santé du vainqueur
il s'agissait bien cette fois de sa
victoire à lyon melbourne australie
premier grand prix de la saison est déjà
beaucoup de choses à raconter
un faux départ provoquées par l'incendié
des deux voitures de l'équipe stewart
ford un second départ et c'est michael
schumacher qui se retrouve en dernière
position après avoir calé il très vite
c'est la grande valse des abandons qui
commence damon hill ancien champion du
monde n'aura fait qu'un tour pour fêter
son 100e grand prix
pourtant l'histoire semble se répéter
les deux mclaren si dominatrices en
passe et prennent la tête de la course
au 2e tour un autre champion du monde
abandonne jacques villeneuve et sa barre
réalise un impressionnant tête à queue à
près de 270 kilomètres heure côté
sorties spectaculaires anne hardy le
pilote de chez williams n'a besson afin
de personnes mi parcours et déjà la
moitié des concurrents son parcours
c'est alors au tour des mclaren de
connaître des problèmes techniques
le bénéfice est pour ferrari il raille
prend la tête laissant hakkinen le
champion du monde en titre derrière lui
michael schumacher se débat avec ses
pneumatiques mais parvient à terminer la
course
à l'arrivée il n'en reste que 8 à 33 ans
au bagne l'irlandais du nord
conquérants fin la victoire devant
franzen et ralf schumacher
un trio gagnant comme une preuve que la
formule 1 peut encore nous surprendre
nouveaux déboires pour ses voyages en
ballon tour du monde aujourd'hui le
ballon des britanniques andy elle seule
n'est que lyne massicotte a achevé sa
course dans le pacifique au large du
japon
les deux hommes ont été récupérés sains
et saufs par des militaires de l'armée
japonaise
les conditions météo très défavorable
explique la décision des pilotes qui ont
choisi de faire amerrir le ballon
théâtre avec cette pièce fascinante
copenhague interprété par pierre vaneck
maya ciment enel sari ce truc que j'ai
le plaisir de recevoir dans une
adaptation signée jean marie besset
copenhague qui relate la rencontre
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale de
ces deux prix nobel de physique
le danois niels bohr travaillant pour
les alliés et son disciple l'allemand
werner heisenberg une rencontre et à
l'historique dont on ignore le contenu
françoise rois ducs bachofen les
agresser là pour dévier si vous voulez
vous fait quelqu'un l'argument une
rencontre post mortem entre deux savants
niels bohr le pape de la physique
quantique comprenez physique atomique et
son élève werner heisenberg leurs
travaux permirent de déboucher sur
l'invention de la bombe atomique
c'est une pièce très très difficile de g
on a un peu le sentiment quand on est
tous les trois la en coulisses et que le
moment du début du spectacle s'avancer
on a l'impression d'être trois petits
points minuscule au pied d'une énorme
montagne dont on n'a pas le sommet
d'ailleurs et que on va tous les chalets
ravir un menu la question que pose
l'auteur et sans lequel de ces deux
personnages s'est mal comporté je
voulais que tu viennes travailler pour
leur âge et zinder qui a travaillé pour
hitler sans lui donner la bombe et sans
tuer personne ou bord qui a permis de
mettre au point pour les années
la bombe de nagasaki et d'hiroshima le
dialogue est éblouissant mais la réponse
échappe sans doute aux deux
protagonistes réfléchir à la
responsabilité sait jamais gillis aveu
trompeur parce que la responsabilité
c'est pas finalement celle d'un
eisenberg vanoppen albert c'est le monde
qu'il a créé c'est le nazisme qui a créé
la guerre les moyens de la guerre avant
ils se sont mis en place en réponse aux
na'vis donc la responsabilité vrai c'est
pas celle d'un eisenberg
tout d'abord c'est la responsabilité de
la société
il les a mis dans une situation de
guerre un décor sobre trois chaises
trois excellents comédiens un théâtre
pur un homme sans complaisance pour une
rencontre qui a peut être changé la face
du monde mais ça reste très peu devant
sarah j'étais comme la critique qui est
unanime et tout à fait subjugué par
cette pièce par son texte par sa mise en
scène par le jeune pierre vaneck par le
vôtre tout à fait et pousse tout flanc
alors je veux savoir comment on rentre
dans le rôle d'un personnage qui est
inhabituel au théâtre même inhabituel
dans la vie celui d'un grand homme de
science un prix nobel de physique
oui puis surtout très particulièrement
un homme qui a vécu qui a existé qui est
mort il ya peu de temps vous faites une
vingtaine d'années mais je crois que ce
qui nous a intéressés surtout c'est de
ses deux pieds de rêver autour des
archétypes plutôt qu'autour des
personnes réelles qui ont existé et de
s'intéresser davantage à la
problématique qu'il véhicule qu'à
essayer d'être au plus près l'individu
tel qu'il a été
c'est plutôt ça qui nous a évidemment on
reviendra sur cette problématique la
responsabilité scientifique mais quand
même ce personnage vous lui donnez une
chaire un caractère la patient la
fébrilité la fragilité et puis vous lui
donnez aussi un accent une sorte de
sonorités particulières
c'est un mélange de souvenirs de
sonorités d'enfance parce que je mon
père était danois est souvent que tu
avais des danois qui venaient à la
maison moi je comprenais plus rien bien
entendu mais il y avait cette musique et
cette musique y rester
dans ma tête depuis que je suis tout
petit et je crois que l'action
d'eisenberg en fait si on regarde bien
et peut-être un peu trop scandinaves
mais bon c'est l'action qui m'est venu
le plus spontané l'arc quand vous êtes
sur scène on a l'impression que vous
êtes le personnage vous donner
entièrement ya pas de retenue il n'y a
pas de calcul parfois on a même presque
l'impression que c'est une souffrance et
être penser à un plaisir mais aussi une
souffrance
c'est un effort c'est un travail c'est
dur c'est parfois difficile
il ya certains soirs où ça vole le quasi
impossible mais bon on est obligé de le
faire mais c'est vrai que moi il me
semble que j'aime bien jouer un peu
comme quand les enfants jouent aux cow
boys et aux indiens donc je joue
complètement le club a eu ce loupé est
mon indien et puis voilà c'est ma nature
c'est à dire que ces deux personnages de
savants deux génies finalement aussi des
comportements très enfants treize
enfants gâtés puis ça c'est aussi ce que
montre cette pièce oui c'est très
curieusement souvent d'ailleurs les gens
qui qui qui sont des grands cerveaux
comme on dit entre guillemets sont
souvent en même temps est très très
étrangement des grands enfants et alors
c'est vrai que ces deux là par exemple
ils n'arrêtent pas de se faire dès des
blagues il n'arrête pas de se faire de
ceux de s'engueuler n'arrête pas de
jouer avec des faux pistolet à bouchon
il n'arrête pas d'être véritablement
enfantin et en même temps complètement
complètement enfermé dans leur équation
dont leur mathématiques dans leur
physique avec une question majeure est
évidemment celle de la responsabilité
scientifique
oui une responsabilité qu'il a et liévy
damman à la création de la bombe
atomique puisqu'à cette époque là en
effet eisenberg dirige le programme
nucléaire allemand nazi bord lui
travaille bien entendu avec les alliés
dans le danemark occupé mais c'est vrai
que au delà de cette de cette
problématique là il ya la problématique
de la responsabilité scientifique
aujourd'hui on pourrait dire c'est
peut-être parce qu'il explique par la
bombe atomique dont on parlerait mais je
sais pas des choses comme le clonage ça
qu'ils posent des questions je crois
vraiment aux gens aujourd'hui et donc la
question de la responsabilité bien sûr
est posée alors cette pièce a évidemment
pose des questions et n'apporte pas
forcément de de réponse et on ne s'est
passé
maintenant à empêcher hitler de voir
l'art map se dit ça ça ne dit pas non
mais là il ya quand même non je crois
que historiquement les documents en fait
n'ont été accessibles qu'à partir de
1992 ils sont restés pendant 50 ans
secret et appartenant services secrets
britanniques
il n'a été publié qu'en 1992 et on a en
effet découvert que haydn bach semblait
être assez avancé dans la possibilité de
fournir la bombe atomique à éclair par
le biais d'un réacteur et par le biais
du plutonium et qu'il a en effet
apparemment pris sur lui de ralentir ce
mouvement pour essayer d'empêcher que
cela puisse avoir l'amour alors quelques
questions mais très rapidement pour
finir des questions qui vous concernent
plus personnellement j'ai envie de dire
que votre image de marque est un peu
sulfureuse un peu violente en tout cas
si cette image là qui accompagnent votre
carrière
ça vous a blessé sept images saveur
c'est vrai oui oui bien sûr je crois que
je suis plus unie un ange ni démon
j'ai sûrement fait des erreurs qui nous
servent selon lui est arrivé d'être trop
passionnés ou d'aller un peu trop loin
ou de dire des choses qu'il ne faut pas
dire c'était c'était ma part de nature
mais je crois que j'étais pas non plus
complètement monstrueux et je crois que
je n'ai pas été aussi violent qu on l'a
prétendu le jeu ne prend pas merci en
tout cas d'avoir à répondre à nos
questions celles sorties cinéma sorti
mercredi prochain de 8 mm avec nicolas
sketch qui joue le rôle d'un détective
privé
c'est une enquête dans le monde du snuff
movies vous savez ce sont ces films
tournés en 8 mm dans lesquels on tue
pour de vrai parce qu'elle deschamps
roger motte
si le 8 mm sert habituellement aux
amateurs a immortalisé les premiers pas
du bébé ou les vacances à la mer les
images que tu as moins elle se découvre
ce jour là vont le glacé d'effroi sur
l'écran une jeune femme est violée et
tuée et ce n'est pas du cinéma
sa mission découvrir qui est pourquoi
j'ai fait ce film parce que le snuff
movies est quelque chose de tout à fait
symbolique
je ne sais pas si c'est quelque chose de
très développée aujourd'hui mais c'est
symbolique de tous les crimes dont sont
victimes certains jeunes en amérique qui
sont enlevés à buzet même assez signer
des jeunes qui rêvent de s'installer à
hollywood et de devenir des stars de
cinéma et qui se retrouvent du mauvais
côté de la route dans l'industrie du
porno dans 8 mm le snuff movies n'est
donc qu'un prétexte à une enquête mais
une enquête en forme de descente aux
enfers celle d'un homme casey et propre
sur lui qui découvre une toute autre
amérique je ne pourrais poser la
question comme wells de négoce alors tu
as une femme une gamine tu as une
résidence le rite un chien qui s'appelle
mais d'heure qu'est ce que tu viens
[ __ ] ici
schéma classique tom waits comme tout
bon privé américain cinéma découvrira le
mal qui est en lui
joel schumacher le réalisateur s'est
trouvé confronté au problème du cinéma
hollywoodien d'aujourd'hui comment
dénoncer le voyeurisme sans être voyeur
il ya toujours le risque d'exciter les
gens qui ont dépensé mal qui sont
attirés par le sadisme et les tortues
mais pour eux mon film c'est de walt
disney ils peuvent trouver ailleurs ce
qu'ils recherchent et n'ont pas besoin
de moi moi j'ai essayé au contraire de
ne pas rendre la violence exitant nice
écrit par le scénariste de seven 8 mm
exploite une veine glauque mais c'est un
thriller phrase un film polémique et qui
permet une fois de plus un nicolas cage
de jouer au funambule sur le fil du
rasoir
la fin de ce journal je vous rappelle le
principal titre stanley kubrick que le
réalisateur américain qui a signé nombre
de chefs-d'oeuvre 2001 odyssée de
l'espace orange mécanique barry lyndon
shining est mort en grande bretagne où
il vivait en reclus depuis des années à
talent inestimable un cinéma de
référence qui aura marqué cette dernière
moitié du siècle
dans un instant la météo laurent romejko
20h50 fair game avec cindy crawford et
william baldwin et à 22h40 en hommage à
stanley kubrick france 2 diffusera
orange mécanique
une première diffusion en clair à la
télévision et puis le dernier journal
florence duprat demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra
ségolène royal à 20h vous retrouver
demain claude sérillon je vous remercie
de votre attention
excellente soirée sur france 2